these chickens are engaged in
important work they produce eggs like
any other chickens
but with the help of their owner they're
also working wonders
transforming the desert this entire area
near the city of
chincha alta in peru is dry and barren
there's almost no rain so it's hardly
suitable for farming
and yet a green plantation is
flourishing
mandarin trees laden with fruit cover an
area of 30 square kilometers it's all
thanks to the chickens
and their resourceful owner
we've been farming in the desert for
many years people thought we were crazy
at first
obviously you only normally grow fruit
and good soil
but today we're producing record numbers
of mandarins
right here in the middle of the desert
it's the chickens that have made the
desert soil fertile
six million of them in all at first
pasco macias was only planning to sell
their eggs
but when he found himself ankle deep in
excrement
he came up with an idea
why not use it as fertilizer
he ants all the leftover chicken feed
too
the birds feed on corn but they're quite
picky
[Music]
this is what's left over we used to burn
it up or throw it away
but now we use it to produce biochar and
that's the central element in our
regenerative fertilizer
basco macias burns the organic waste in
a controlled process called pyrolysis
it's a centuries-old method used by the
indigenous peoples of the amazon
biochar is rich in nutrients an ideal
source of food for the trees
but then he adds the chicken excrement
too
along with a few other ingredients
turning it all into fertilizer pellets
some of them he uses for the mandarin
plantation
the rest he sells
this circular economy allows us to make
everything efficient
it's really nothing new it's actually
the way that nature works
the principle is simple resources are
used and reused as long as possible
saving money and avoiding waste unlike
normal methods
in the capital lima the german
development agency
giz is advising the peruvian environment
ministry
on how to encourage more businesses to
move to a circular economy
the program is financed by the german
government's international climate
initiative
[Music]
i'm very grateful to be part of this
project and for the opportunity to
support an initiative like this
it's a paradigm shift a whole different
way of thinking
so we need to provide help to ensure
this shift will be successful
so she talks to business owners who've
already made the change to learn from
their experience
like palmyra ocampo
he's a chef in lima and buys all his
vegetables from an organic farm
on the menu today fennel
the aroma of fennel is intense
delicious
he uses every part of the plant
including the bits other chefs normally
throw away
like the flowers
i'm going to take some of these flowers
they have a great aroma
palmiro has founded an initiative called
corey
which means treasure in the indigenous
quechua language
part of the idea is to train other chefs
to use food in its entirety
we founded corey with the aim of making
peruvian cuisine more sustainable
by optimizing our use of food the aim is
to avoid food waste and hunger in peru
he takes his freshly harvested
vegetables to a local soup kitchen
staff here are grateful for tips they
work as volunteers cooking for the needy
they can't afford to throw anything away
a meal here
costs one euro but for those without an
income
it's available for free
[Music]
ronald vargaman shows the cooking team a
new recipe
a fennel and beetroot salad that uses
every part of the vegetable
it's served with a vinaigrette made of
fruit peel and a kind of peppercorn
made of dried papaya seeds look at this
papaya we can spoon out the seeds
wonderfully
without losing anything
normally the seeds and peel would land
in the trash
here they end up in the sauce
the fennel flowers provide the finishing
touch
i'm happy and grateful we were throwing
a lot away before
now we use it and don't waste anything
the chefs are now showing others how
it's done bosco macias also wants to
share his idea for fertilizer
and see this form of circular economy
take off elsewhere
if fruit can flourish in the desert the
possibilities
are surely endless
you